isabelle je pense qu'on a déjà touché
derrière parce qu'elle est déjà venu sur
le plateau de ça même sarko n'est
peut-être pas mais je crois qu'il ya un
jeu valable jusqu au décès soit d'écouté
où il va alors se dire que la gaule gelé
à serrer les rangs pour ne pas dire
continuellement quitte une tente de prix
des fils mais c'est appris à glisser
télévisuelle donc je l'aï tellement je
n'ai aucune préférence à part dès
maintenant se présente parce que d'aller
plus copains mais j'ai pas tout chanteur
préféré d'acheter
ils sont tous au taquet alors qui est
très chiant c'est d'attendre que ce
chien de patientes est d'ailleurs facile
et du faucon attend un petit peu trop
dans les loges
très chiant c'est surtout je crois que
c'est les femmes
beaucoup de femmes sont très chiante oui
mais on préfère les taux pour des
réalités
alors ouais ça me plairait en fait
l'idée ce que j'aimerais bien placé le
voilà on est tous en tout pendant 20 ans
via mail est mon équipe de foot préférée
c'est très bien paris saint germain
je suis comme tous ces jeunes qui
kiffent omnibulé par la pop culture
je pense que c'est si réguler même parce
que je lire d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
que nous nous sommes connus sur la
terrasse de roland garros foucault
animeront une émission sur les coulisses
de ce tournoi non comment il s'appelle
la jolie fille aînée à gâteau proulx
voilà moi je suis tout serait normal sur
siège est à l'évasion
benjamin et vous bien et ben voilà ce
que vous couper tous je pense que c'est
mathieu tu es fan de sport automobile
qui celui-là lé feu et l'a étendu très
frais qui fera là on n'est jamais
d'accord j'avais vous verrez au final
christian trois bons alors qu'on était
ensemble comment j'étais avec
l'olympique marseille
c'est un atout dans les voeux en tant
que marché des murs bien que l'olympique
de marseille voilà mais c'est comme ça
en plus on avait toi c'est normal est ce
que c'est et pierre ménès qu'apparente
de supporter paris c'est ça qu'il faut
se dire voilà ça
[Musique]